-Our next guest
is an Emmy-winning
actress and comedian
you know from her
critically acclaimed series
"Crazy Ex-Girlfriend."
Her Off-Broadway show,
"Death, Let Me Do My Show,"
opens at the Orpheum Theatre
in New York, December 7th.
She also stars
in the Max series "Julia."
New episodes premiere Thursdays.
Let's take a look.
-You got any advice
for an old girl
navigating the West Coast?
-Well, it usually
goes one of two ways.
If you're a hit, then you grow.
Not just your audience,
but you, your power.
And you feel it,
and it feels good
and it feels permanent.
But that's a trap,
because nothing in L.A.
is ever permanent.
-Please welcome back
to the show
our friend Rachel Bloom,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Wow!
-It is so good to see you again.
-It's so good to be here.
-This is such a weird night
for you to be here,
because you actually
met Michael Shannon before.
You were on the show
"Lip Sync Battle" together.
-Yep.
-You took him on head-to-head.
He-lip synched an R.E.M. song,
which is --
He's gonna sing one later.
"End of the World
as We Know It."
And he defeated you?
-Yes. I lost to him.
To be fair, I was on
"Lip Sync Battle"
with him before my show
had premiered.
So to the audience
watching "Lip Sync Battle,"
it was a famous person
and some unknown woman.
-Yeah.
-They might as well have, like,
picked me off of the street,
and they were like,
"Oh, good for her.
She was working
at that restaurant,
and they found her."
Like, they
truly had no idea who I was.
So, look, he was great,
but it wasn't a fair fight.
I'll say that.
-Okay, great.
You know, today, who knows
how the vote would go?
-But here's the thing.
This is not the first time
I've come in second
to Michael Shannon
doing R.E.M. on a TV show.
-Yeah, but if it happens
a third time,
something weird is going on.
I was saying earlier,
this is a fantastic poster
for your show.
-It's a great --
-It is a great --
This is a show you planned
to do in 2020.
COVID obviously interfered.
You did a run in the fall and
and now you're doing it again.
Very personal show.
What sort of set you
on the path of doing this?
-Yeah, so, I was planning to do
a big comedy -- musical-comedy
special and show in 2020
and I was planning it in 2019.
I gave birth in late March 2020.
A bunch of sad things
happened around that.
I was in my office, where I had
written all of the bullet points
for my planned stand-up
musical show with my daughter,
in the middle of a pandemic.
I was grieving my friend,
who had passed away
a week
after my daughter was born,
and I was looking at these
bullet points for this special.
And when you look at bullet
points of a stand-up set,
nothing makes you feel worse
about yourself as a comedian.
Like, the bullet points --
Basically, bullet points,
it's a way that you remind
yourself, so it's one word,
where it's like
"pencil," "booger."
One of them was like "old-lady
pop song?" -- question mark.
Like, I didn't even
have enough confidence
to not put a question mark.
And I -- "Old-lady pop song"
was pretty good, though.
It was -- The idea --
It was the idea that
all of our pop stars
are so young,
but why should we rely
on young people
to tell us about our culture?
So I want, like,
an old-lady pop star.
-Yeah.
-Okay, that's a middling
response, and I'm glad that I...
-But you would
have done a song.
-I'm glad that I moved on.
It was a whole song.
You have to actually --
To get the context,
you actually have
to hear the lyrics.
But this is really good
feedback for me.
-But they don't understand.
That's when -- You just laid out
a premise right there.
I think it's a very
strong premise.
-Yeah, but this is my unpaid
writers room, so thank you.
Uh-oh!
-Another strike!
-Now they're on strike!
-[ Chanting ] One more strike!
-Yeah, so I was like,
"I can't do this same show now.
The world has changed.
My life has changed."
I'm in the middle of what was
my office with my newborn child.
I'm breastfeeding.
My life is somewhat
of a shambles.
And so that's
what inspired this show.
I basically try to do the show
I wanted to do in 2020,
and then there is an interloper
in the form of death.
-I want to say
I am always the most impressed
and I do feel the best work
comes out of a creative person
who is willing to
throw away work.
You know, because, again, once
those note cards are on the
wall -- and I've
been there, too --
you can't stop thinking
about all the work
you've already put into it,
and it seems insane
to throw it away.
Yet, anytime you talk
to somebody who tells you,
"Yeah, I knew it wasn't
the right stuff
and I threw it away,"
that's when the great thing
comes out of it.
So I do applaud that choice.
-Thank you.
And what sucks is, I tried
to keep a lot of my old material
in the show,
and it all just lifted out.
And the one thing that's left,
I can't say the title
on television,
but let's just say
it's about a certain tree
that smells up
the entire country every year.
And people call
this tree a thing.
-Alright.
-It's a tree
that smells like semen.
I think I can say semen, right?
Semen is scientific.
-Yeah.
-It's the semen tree.
-Okay, great.
-But I say another word for it.
-I think everybody here
wants to come to this show now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got you.
You know, you talk about
death as a theme and you talk --
There's a story about your dog
not passing away,
but you received
a very interesting letter.
Can you explain the story here?
-Yeah.
So, we got a business manager
a couple years ago,
and it's someone who kind of
looks over your finances,
because I am financially
incapable of anything.
And he said,
"Oh, you have a dog.
I'm going to put you
on something
called pet health insurance."
And then a week later
he said, "Ah, you know what?
I found you a cheaper
health insurance.
I switched you to that."
So, unbeknownst to us,
the way he got us
out of the first
pet health insurance was
he told the company
our dog died.
-Yeah.
-So, one day,
I'm walking my dog,
and then I come home and I open
up the mail to find this.
-Yeah. Right.
-Yeah, so,
"With deepest sympathy."
If you open up
that card there, Seth --
-A lot of people
did a lot of work.
-Yeah. So, this is
a condolence card
signed by everyone
who worked at this,
turns out,
mom-and-pop insurance company.
-Yeah.
-So, I am looking at this card
and I am now being told
that a dog that I've been
walking for the past half-hour
is, in fact, dead.
Yeah.
-And it messed
with my head for a while.
And this is the real card.
And I have it laminated
in my drawer,
and I take it out
and look at it a lot.
-Well, the good news is,
you you saved 20 bucks a month.
So there you go.
[ Laughter ]
You were very kind to bring --
You know, again,
I think it's very helpful
when people talk about
that creative process
and looking things on the wall
and realizing it's not right.
And also early performance.
-Yes.
-You have some photos of some of
your early times in New York.
And most of these, I would
imagine when you look at them,
your memory is of the anxiety.
Is that safe to say?
-Oh, no.
You know, I actually have
really good memories of my time
performing in New York.
Oh, yeah, this is so great.
So, this is a picture of me
on my college sketch group.
I'm in a sketch with my friend
Matt and I'm on a date.
It was so fun.
What you don't see here is,
at the time,
I was in a secret relationship
with a man
who was ashamed to be with me.
And this was the latest
in a continuing pattern
of going for unavailable men
who were ashamed of me.
And so part of the reason
I'm so happy in this sketch
is because, for once,
I can be openly in love
with someone,
even if it's just pretend.
-That's great.
-Good times.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
-Now, what were you
going through here?
-This brings up such nostalgia.
So, obviously here,
I'm dressed as a bear.
I was the most unhappy
I'd ever been in my life.
So, I found out later
that I have
generalized anxiety disorder,
but at this time,
it had kind of pendulumed to
general depression.
And the secret relationship
was over,
but that guy was going to be
at the sketch show this night.
So I was like,
"I have to look hot."
Now, luckily, my depression made
me kind of not want to eat,
so I was very skinny,
so I did look hot
despite the fact
I was dressed as a bear.
-Yeah. It's a good memory there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's just such good --
It's just like nostalgia bath.
-Yeah.
-Oh, right.
Okay, this is my first time
doing stand-up.
Don't worry. The secret
relationship was over.
But I will say that
at this moment,
the OCD intrusive thoughts
that I had had
as a kid reared their head again
in adulthood.
And so as I was doing
this first stand-up set,
it felt as if my body
was separate from my mind.
But I still killed.
-Alright, great.
That's all that matters.
In the end, our desperate need
to please strangers.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
New York comedy -- so fun.
-How old is
your little one now?
-She's 3 1/2.
-3 1/2.
You said something
that very much rang true for me,
which is, when you have a child,
especially that first child,
you feel as though
you were cosplaying as a parent.
-Yeah, yeah. The first --
I don't know about you.
The first year
and a half I had a kid,
I kept thinking,
"When are these people
going to come
and pick up their baby?"
-Yeah.
-Like, "Someone
needs to take her."
And then now I say things --
Well, first of all,
and you've talked about this
in your stand-up,
just with the voice of like,
"Wow!
Those are some big feelings."
You know, when she says
just the worst things to you,
which you never -- If someone
cuts you off in traffic,
you wouldn't pull them over
and be like, "Hey,
you have some big feelings
right there.
Do you want to talk about them?
Do you want to watch
'Daniel Tiger'?"
And then the way
that I sometimes speak to her
are ways
that I would never speak to --
"Hey, do not!
We don't pull the dog's tail.
We do not.
We don't pull any dog's tail."
Like, I couldn't -- I would be
sued if I did that at work.
But it just -- It feels like
you're doing an impression
of a parent sometimes.
-Yeah. Finally, we showed
a clip of "Julia"
that's sort of, like,
a period-piece show
about Julia Child.
Do you enjoy that?
-I love it.
I thought it was so fun.
My family's from Boston,
and so I filmed it in Boston.
And it takes place
in the early '60s,
so it kind of felt
like I was cosplaying
as someone who knew my family.
That was a callback to earlier.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And what I find
kind of relieving is,
when you were in the '60s,
you only got -- Women got
their hair done once a week,
and then your only job
was to maintain.
And we think of
the '60s as this,
oh, restrictive time for women.
But how easy is that?
We didn't have to look at TikTok
mermaid-wave tutorials.
You got your hair done
once a week.
And then, similarly, there's all
this pressure to just,
"Oh, you got to work out
and have a skinny body."
But that's what
a girdle was for.
And that's why Spanx
are so popular.
They're basically girdles.
Girdles have come back because
women have always wanted --
We've always wanted to
smooth out our lumps, right?
And, so, it's a lot easier
to wear a girdle,
to wear shapewear than to wish
for a different body type.
So I found it actually
very empowering
to wear the shapewear
and have my hair done.
I felt like I could focus
on other things
because someone else
was doing it for me.
-Well, there you go.
That's a ringing endorsement.
A ringing endorsement
of the times.
-Yeah.
-It is always such a delight
to have you back here.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations on your show.
-Thank you.
-You guys, that's Rachel Bloom,
everybody.
"Death, Let Me Do My Show"
opens at the Orpheum Theatre
on December 7th,
and new episodes of "Julia"
premiere Thursdays on Max.
We'll be right back
with music from
Michael Shannon
and Jason Narducy.